your kids think of weird stuff do you
have kids with active imagine oh yeah
yeah both of them go full weirdo 24
hours a day basically Mike duck my
oldest daughter actually she how old is
she
she's sick I don't know she's eight did
she say okay somebody checked that yeah
she said you're a really good day
expensive Oh we'll find out what the
media she says that she's a witch she's
convinced that she's a witch she gets
very witchy and she we were okay we were
in Sedona once you know it's Sedona
that's very new agey place in Arizona
she had no idea she's Jewish barely even
goes to Sunday school at that age she
was like 2 years ago and she she got to
Sedona and it's supposed to be like
vortexes and new agey stuff and crystals
it's all her it's well they're there
they're loaded with crystals they're
polluted with it yeah and she got a robe
on and we lit a fire in the hotel and
she sat down very straight and she goes
I think I shall pray and we were both of
you're unpacking me like what we have
that savory action what made her I mean
that's weird that she was picking up on
the energy of Sedona mantling channeling
maybe she's a witch what okay what why
does she think she's aware uh-huh
I I don't know what I think she's a
witch man like she goes to check this
out she this is what she says and I
believe her to a degree well she says
every night at 2:00 a.m. she leaves the
house and goes to which ceremonies in
the woods
and she she describes them elaborately
like to the point where my wife and I
are like oh this is so cute this is this
is detailed this is super detail misses
a question has keeping an eye on her at
2:00 in the morning what if she I mean
first of all you don't know her age so
it's not like you're on the situation of
this guy what if she what if she is
leaving the house and going to which
ceremonies who I am man
look if she can get up for school the
next day and get good grades cocaine in
the woods
[Laughter]
you